moins de rentrées d'argent et plus de
dépenses notamment avec les fermetures
des écoles et des cantines ici dans le
quartier du chemin vert le confinement à
aggraver la situation des familles les
plus précaires
très vite certains habitants ont
souhaité prendre les choses en main
notamment les jeunes du collectif chemin
vert ils se sont donné pour mission de
s'assurer que tous ici dans ce quartier
et de quoi se nourrir
si anna birama boys
la plupart d'entre eux ont grandi dans
ce quartier du chemin vert avec
l'épidémie du coronavirus ils ont
découvert l'extrême précarité de
certaines personnes dans leur voisinage
en fait on se connaît tous bonjour mon
ce pas ce qui se passe en fait vraiment
chez les gens on s'est passé vraiment
les gens ont un bon train de vie où les
gens vraiment une ville précaire en fait
j'ai vu que en fait vraiment la plupart
des gens ont vraiment une rude précaires
et ça ça m'a fait vraiment mal donc
c'est pour ça que je me donne vraiment à
fond à fond à fond
plusieurs fois par semaine depuis le
début du confinement le petit groupe
chargé de caddies fait le tour des
barres d'immeubles pour distribuer les
colis alimentaires et au fil du temps le
dispositif est maintenant bien rodée ça
c'est les personnes qui n'ont jamais été
livrés donc ils sont prioritaires
voilà c'est vraiment les personnes qui
ont fait la première demande en fait on
lui met en rouge et comme ça on vous on
en est on arrive à l'assurance ils ont
sali ouais donc à la presse des
personnes ont écrit
mais le nombre de personnes par an le
nombre de personne dans la famille
l'occasion aussi de s'assurer que les
plus vulnérables les personnes âgées ou
isolées se porte bien
[Musique]
au départ le collectif ne pensait et dès
que les habitants du quartier
l'un des plus pauvres de la ville mais
très vite la demande a explosé
on reçoit des appels de personnes qui
nous disent voilà on a donc sonné telle
ou telle famille qui est vraiment dans
la précarité
est-ce que vous pouvez les aider et
c'est donc à ce moment là on leur ajoute
également sur notre liste confinement
elle a déjà commencé en mars donc pas le
temps d'attentes deux mois pour avoir
des aides
il fallait agir dans l'urgence mais
aujourd'hui le collectif craint que
cette crise ne s'installe durablement
des jeunes issus de quartiers cède
naturellement on a des structures on a
des collectifs deux fonctions
franchement on peut on peut s'aider nous
mêmes mais d'un coteau a besoin aussi de
porte cette crise économique a révélé
des inégalités sociales qui existent
depuis plusieurs années maintenant dans
le département de la seine saint denis
l'un des plus pauvres de france
et si ici comme ailleurs le
déconfinement est très attendu pointe
déjà une nouvelle angoisse celle de la
crise économique qui risquent de suivre
et qui frapperait inévitablement elle
les plus précaires